Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Rawkode live, and I am your
host, David Flanagan.
Today, I am joined by Lucas from Loft
who is gonna interest introduce us to their
new open source project, DevPod.
Hello, Lucas. How are you? Hey, David.
I'm doing alright. Thanks for having me on.
Yeah. It's been a while. We haven't done
a session like this for a long, long
time, so it's nice to have you back
in the hot seat and ready to show
us something new and cool today.
For
anyone who hasn't seen our previous episode or
isn't familiar with you and your work, could
you please take a few moments to introduce
yourself and tell us what you've been up
to?
Yeah. Sure. I'm Lucas.
I'm one of the founders of Loft Labs.
What we do with our product Loft is
essentially provide, you know, building blocks for
platform engineers who have to build platforms on
top of Kubernetes
to provision, you know, clusters for the engineering
teams, etcetera, in, you know, one of these
building blocks. And I think that's the last
time we've spoken, David, as vCosta. That's a
pretty popular open source project we launched.
We also maintain the DevSpace
project, which we handed over as a sandbox
project to the CNCF.
And now we're on our third project, and
that's that's what we're talking about today.
Nice. Awesome. So the the project was announced
last week, I believe.
It's called DevPod, and I know that it's
a tool
that sits on top of dev containers and
tries to give people virtual
machines or infrastructure with all the tooling that
they need to work on a project. Is
that am I on the right line, sir?
Yeah. That wraps it up pretty well. Yeah.
We announced it last Tuesday.
And DevPod,
the idea is essentially, you know, you want
something like code spaces,
but you don't want it as a hosted
managed service that kind of locks you into
a specific infra,
you essentially want that flexibility of, you know,
spinning things up in your own AWS account
or on Kubernetes
or even a local Docker desktop and give
it a freedom to switch back and forth
whenever you want to do so. Right? You
can save some cost by staying locally,
and then you go to AWS whenever you
need that power. And it really gives you
the flexibility to, you know, dynamically switch between
these environments. I think that's the that's the
true true power of this new project.
Nice.
I'm curious. Like,
you know, obviously, there's been a substantial, I
would assume, amount of effort and teamwork that's
been entered us from the lost side to
try and and make this a product that
you can open source and put in the
hands of thousands to tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of developers. Like, what were
the driving factors that, you know, you're all
sat in Loft HQ one day drinking your
coffee and you went, you know what? We
should build this. Like, what was the original
driving factor then?
Yeah. I guess Loft HQ is more like,
you know, Slack channels and
Zoom sessions because we're fully distributed.
But, yeah, you're right. I think
we were, you know, we were thinking about
how can we you know, obviously, we were
looking at these solutions, GitPod,
Codespaces,
etcetera, and everything that that happened in that
space
also for our own team. Right? And, you
know, we're, like, over 20 people now.
There's
folks from the design side reviewing things that
get changed in the UI.
Then, you know, product wants to have a
look before things are released.
And then we have the open source community
contributing to our projects.
And we are thinking, how can we make
it easier for people to, you know, just
launch an environment,
spin up a certain branch, contribute a little
bit? And,
yeah, we were we were looking at code
spaces because we're using, you know, repositories on
GitHub or open source projects on GitHub, obviously.
But then,
you know, locking people into into that very
specific environment. I mean, the experience of launching
it is great if you are on GitHub.
Right?
But what if you're not on GitHub? Or
what if you are,
you know, if you don't wanna pay
for that premium that essentially
they charge for these environments and you just
wanna have that experience locally or you just
wanna have that experience in your own Kubernetes
clusters and EKS. Right?
We were asking us these questions, and we
didn't really find a great answer for that
anywhere.
So we just started
building things internally. I think, you know, our
CTO, Fabian, and and my cofounder, he's
you know, he just sometimes just pulls things
together over a weekend, and that was the
same thing with DevPod. And that was, like,
an initial prototype. And that's already, like, I
don't know, five or six months,
you know, ago at this point. And,
you know, it it seemed very promising and
exciting, and we're like, okay. Maybe we should,
you know, invest some time here and actually
build a legit open source project out of
this. And, yeah, that's what we did. And
and, you know, now we're presenting it to
the world. We had a little bit of
a, you know, private better kind of session
a few weeks ago with some of our
customers because they've expressed interest in in this
topic, and we're like, oh, even better. You
know, people that are already using our tooling
would see additional value here.
So let's let's invest some time and and
build this thing and get it off the
ground.
Nice.
I love how I started the conversation with
you must have invested a serious amount of
effort and people time and everything, and you're
like, yeah. One person built it over a
weekend. At least, you know, the proof of
concept.
It does all the best I can. Was
the version.
Yeah. And that was the alpha version zero,
I think. But, yeah, I think now,
obviously, there's there's, you know, more parts of
our engineering team involved. So let let's definitely
give credit to to all of the folks
that have contributed internally.
And, yeah, most exciting thing is actually we've
already seen the first
you know, DevPod has this provider concept,
and from
Pulumi
has, over the weekend, apparently, created a scale
way
provider for for DevPod. So we even see
the first, like, bigger community contributions.
It was super surprising. We made the repository
public, I think, three or four hours before,
you know, announcing it to the public just
to make sure we test everything, upgrade procedures,
and how how all of that works with
the public repository.
And then we got the first pull request
even before the press release.
Like, dang it. Like, people are onto this.
Nice.
Alright. Well, obviously, with Rawkode Live, I'm gonna
try and use DevPod. We're gonna work through
what that process looks like and show people
how to get started. But I have one
more question before we do that if you're
happy to answer it. And I'm curious. Right?
Looking
at the the loft portfolio of open source
projects, you've got v cluster that I can
run-in my Kubernetes clusters to facilitate virtual clusters
for multiple use cases,
which I think ties in quite nicely maybe
with what we're gonna see with DevPod. And
then we also have DevSpace, which also kind
of is
I don't know if it's tangential or not,
but it's very close to what DevPod's doing
and where it provides development environments for software
to point to Kubernetes, maybe more. I'm not
that familiar. So I'm curious about how do
these work together?
Is there a grand plan there to kinda
take over that developer experience? Do I need
to use all three? What does that look
like?
Yeah. That's a that's a very good question.
Actually, a lot of our
community members who are already familiar with DevSpace,
when we presented DevPod to them, they had
that exact same question. Isn't there a lot
of overlap here? Right? But
DevPod is kind of under DevSpace.
So DevSpace is the tool that deploys your
containers to Kubernetes and creates this hot reloading
workflow
for these containers. Right?
What DevPod does is it launches
the environment to then start your IDE in.
So it is a layer lower when you're
thinking about what do I need to develop
an an application.
You know, you do need an IDE. You
do need a, you know, a linter.
You don't need a debugger. You do need
all these things locally,
and
we're trying to get rid of that by
essentially moving that into a DevPod. So it's
very, very likely that if you're working with
Kubernetes and you love to work with DevSpace
or another tool like Scaffold or, you know,
any of these other tools out there, you
would launch a DevPod, and then you launch
DevSpace
DevSpace from within that DevPod.
That's how it would typically
work together.
But DevPod is a little broader than DevSpace
because even if you don't if if Kubernetes
is not your target environment,
you can launch a DevPod
and work directly in there on top of,
you know, Docker
and without Kubernetes, right, which is something that
DevSpace doesn't do at all.
Nice.
Alright. That makes sense to me, you know,
especially even the tie in NV cluster where
you give your developers the ability to provision
virtual clusters and then, you know, big huge
dev Kubernetes cluster where they can then have
their dev pods where they run their DevSpace.
I think I understand that flow. Think it
makes sense. And I think it I mean,
it's very interesting to me personally. One, I'm
a developer advocate and I travel to a
lot of events and I I travel with
a MacBook Air.
It's not slow, but for a dev environment,
it's also not great.
And also for the last what Yeah. Three
years, I've had an m one or m
two MacBook and I've gotta say, you I
run into nothing but problems, especially compiling Go
and Rust and, you know, I'm pulling container
images which are only built for AMD sixty
four and I'm pulling my head out going
there has to be a better way. I
can already see the draw to have a
tool like DevPod
where I can get an environment. Now, you
said you can run it locally and that's
great, but I I think for me, I'm
gonna be like, okay. I wanna spin up
a scale way or an AWS instance. Use
that as my DevBox and have it managed
for me with the tools that I need.
And I'm hoping that's what we're we're gonna
see today.
Yeah.
That's a repeatability we're we're aiming we're aiming
for with DevPod.
Awesome. Alright. Shall we start having some fun?
Yeah. I'm excited. I know you always take
these tools apart, so I'm I'm really excited
to to see what you're doing with DevPod
this time.
Alright. Well, I've hopefully, you everyone can see
my screen now. The website is available if
people wanna check that out at devpod.sh.
So go there for all the documentation,
links to download DevPod, and link to the
GitHub repository
too.
It's a nice website, you know. It's it's
superficial things go. They're also important. It's nice
when you have a developer tool that has
a shiny website for people to kinda understand
what the use case is. I'm not gonna
spend any time on this. I just kinda
wanna go straight to the documentation
and see what we can do.
Now, I did cheat a little bit
mostly because I was curious last week and
I wanted to see what DevPod was and
I'm always curious to see when things prepared.
I agree. So I I had installed DevPod,
but I haven't done anything with it. So
here we go.
And this is our DevPod UI.
Hold on. I haven't set up any providers
except for I think I clicked the docker
one, but that's where we are. But I'm
assuming step one is DevPod doesn't do anything
without one of those providers. So we need
to configure one or more so that we
have the ability to create the developer environments.
Correct? That's correct. Yes. Nice.
Alright. Let's see. Yeah. I did add the
Docker one. So I don't wanna use this,
but I'm assuming it just runs containers
and my Docker daemon, is Docker desktop. Right?
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Correct. Yeah. It just connects to
your local Docker daemon to kinda spin up
a, you know, DevPod as a container.
And then I think it gives you access
to the local
Docker as well, so you can run Docker
builds, etcetera, even inside that DevPod.
That's the idea behind it. If you use
one of the other providers,
there's providers that provision VMs. We call them
machine providers.
That would be like AWS
or
Google Cloud and and things like that where
you actually spin up a VM. And then
it would
deploy
Docker inside that VM
and then stand up the DevPod agent inside
that VM and then launch a DevPod container
in there. So whether you're using the local
Docker provider or one of the machine remote
providers,
we're always launching Docker inside of it and
then always launching the DevPod as a container
essentially.
Okay.
That makes sense, I guess. So I guess
we should show the local Docker one, which
means I'll need to start Docker.
Is there anything else in the UI that
we need to kind of play with right
now, or are we just gonna wait for
Docker to start up and create our first
workspace?
Yeah. I think that should work. You can
hit create workspace here. I think even while
it's loading, we can explore what
happens over here.
Yeah. The first thing is you have to
enter the source. Right? You either select a
folder locally or you type in a git
repository,
wherever you have a dev container JSON or
something ready.
And then on the right hand side, see
links for, like, you know, Python or Node.
Js, kind of quick starts.
Microsoft has these quick starts for
GitHub
code spaces,
and, you know, we are essentially using these
examples
without any modification to show people, hey, this
is just like Codespaces.
I should use the same
definition. That's why it works out of the
box. But works of any repository, essentially, especially
if you have the dev container JSON
configured out in there.
Okay. So, I mean, what I did type
there was my Contrail project, but I don't
believe we have a dev container JSON.
No. We don't. Is that a problem?
I actually think it may guess
what
There is a cargo.com. The right image would
be. If that helps. I mean, we can
we can always try it and and check
it out if it works or not.
Let's see.
I always like to just see what happens.
So hey. Look. I detected that. I know
this is really small. I don't think I
can zoom in on a Mac app, but
at least I'm I don't know how to
do that. But it does say detective project
language rust,
and it is pulling down dev containers Rust
latest. So
I guess it work. I can't promise you
that the application will actually launch in there
because it's it just takes, like, a default,
like, Rust image. Right?
If you have a dev dev container JSON,
you can obviously specify all of these things.
But we're trying our best to kind of
guess what you need. That's
the that's the approach here.
Yeah. I think this might work.
It also says it's downloading
Versus Code.
So this is now open my local Versus
Code, and it's setting up
SSH remote
container session. Yeah. Correct. Yeah. It it essentially
created that DevPod inside the container, and then
it connected you
to that via SSH. You see that on
the left bottom corner that it says the
SSH connection there. Yep.
Nice.
So I'm well, I don't have my macros,
but that's okay. That's probably my fault.
I don't know how to type. There we
go. So this is
yeah.
Linux machine. And because it's local desktop, we're
getting
AMD sixty four.
And in theory, I should just be able
to run a cargo build. Right?
Yeah. Fingers crossed.
Well, I can actually already see that I
have Rust analyzer in my Versus code, and
it's actually kind of doing all the fetch
and stuff at the moment. So we'll give
that a second. So maybe we can dive
into actually
what kind of happened here. So we added
a new workspace to DevPod.
We now have this thing where I can
just open it. That's there forever now. Right?
Even if I close this, I can assume
it. I can just restart this whenever I
want.
Yeah. Open is just gonna reconnect the IDE,
right, to this environment.
And if you hit the three little dots,
you also see it says, like, start with,
which essentially lets you open it with other
IDEs
in case like, the default one you selected
for your Docker provider
was Docker desktop
sorry, Versus Code on the desktop. But you
could also save Versus Code in a browser,
and then it would just connect you to
that one.
Yeah. I'm gonna try it.
It's got a light color theme by default.
I'm not sure how I feel about that,
but
that's Versus Code's problem, not yours.
Yeah. Here we go.
This is neat.
See, I I went through a little phase
of trying just, like, to work from a
Chromebook for so long and could never get
it to work. And it feels like this
may have been the missing thing that I
needed,
like, Versus Code browser support at a remote
container with the tools that I need. That
would've been pretty cool. Yeah. I mean, you
won't believe it, but one of the first
issues that were opened were, like, can you
support iPads as well?
And we're, like, dang it. Now we gotta
create an iPad app for this.
People do love like, I the amount of
times I see people with their iPads at
conferences and they've got a little keyboard on
it which I I have tried so hard
to be able to type on is impossible.
But they do seem to use
like a a web based Versus code and
and try to do stuff. So, yeah.
Yeah. Alright. Not not for me. Don't they
have the
I'm not sure if they have, like, a
keyboard you can attach with the iPads as
well, like, you know, like the Surface
ones have for Microsoft.
I thought you well, there's just MagSafe attachment,
but it does give you a USB c
slot. You can go nuts, I suppose. Oh,
okay.
Alright.
So that's,
you know, that's kinda cool. We're now building
our application. It looks like it's gonna build
because it's 75%
through, and we didn't get an error from
Versus Code to see that the rust I
know how your build failed. So I'm assuming
in a few moments, we all have went
from
zero
tooling
to an IDE with rust support and an
application that compiles.
Well, I think that's pretty cool.
But the UI is not the only way
to do this. Right? When I was in
the settings,
I did see add CLI to path and
I've got a green tech which means I
have the CLI. So I'm assuming if I
want to, I don't really need to work
with the UI at all.
Yeah. Actually, what the UI does
under the hood, whenever you click any kind
of button to create something, it actually just
runs the CLI command under the hood. The
adding to your path is really just more
of a convenience thing, so you can also
access the CLI directly.
But, yeah, every everything ties back to a
CLI command under the hood.
Okay.
Fill up my CLI.
Alright. So I can just do that. There
we go.
Cool.
So shall we try a different provider?
Yeah. I can see the the help page.
So I know I should probably be, like,
going through your get started, guys. I'm trying
to be a bit more pragmatic here, but
I also just
wanted to play with it. So,
we're kinda seeing the browser, and we've seen
Versus code. I I don't use any of
these other things. I'm not that fast.
So let's see if we can manage some
providers.
Oh, I'm just seeing we do have a
Vim quick start because that was another question
that came up in a in a previous
livestream, and I'm like, I don't know how
to connect this to Vim. Like, oh, I
guess we have a quick start for that
as well.
Vim?
Which I guess makes sense. Like, if you
scroll down, it probably just says, like, connect
via SSH and then
Yes.
Yeah.
That's Aliases. Right? Is is that integration to
to connect to it.
I'm curious if that's modified my SSH config
or my, yeah, I guess it has done
probably.
I guess we'll find out when I spin
up a remote provider because it probably won't
do anything if I don't have one.
So let's see if we can get that
working. In fact, for the build.
Ah,
close.
What did I miss?
I'm sure I've got some oh, I probably
have like an open SSL dependency or something
that's needed. So let's close that for now.
So DevPod
list,
DevPods
dot, I suppose.
Mhmm. Cool.
Alright. DevPod
provider
add.
And then
Yeah. You'd essentially
so, typically, you
need the provider specified
in,
you know, some kind of repository.
I think there are default providers. You can
see that here, like, at docker
and at AWS. Right? That's, the default providers.
But you could also point it at a
repository
or at a YAML file
like the scale web provider that Engen
wrote, and then it would essentially pull the
specification from there.
Okay.
If you in this provider, if you go
to the,
like, the gcloud,
like, we just map gcloud to the actual
repository.
Right? If you look at the releases here
on the right hand side,
you see that there's one release of this
provider.
And in that provider,
in the assets, if you scroll down,
I think yeah. If you click show all
assets, it should share provider YAML. That's essentially
the file that specifies
how this provider
is being run
within DevPod.
Okay. So Yeah. It's like, like, the name,
the version. Right?
And then a whole bunch of commands, available
options,
like, region, etcetera. Like, everything that you've seen
in the in the UI, when there's a
drop down show you, you know, which region
you can select, right, it essentially comes from
this provider YAML file.
Okay. Well,
I'm gonna very quickly off screen in another
window, make sure my Google Cloud is authenticated
against the correct account,
not one of my customers' accounts,
and then I'll add the provider.
But I seen why am I doing this?
Because I seen when we were here
that it said, be aware
authentication is tangent obtain just in the g
cloud CLI. And so I just wanna make
sure that Yes.
I'm on the right account before I do
anything
terrible.
And my customers Yeah. There's two options to
authenticate it. I think the the safest and
the default option is to just use g
cloud CLI because, you know, whatever your
authentication
mechanism is with Google Cloud, it has it
in your,
you know, in your key chain or in
your in your, you know, Microsoft store
that they have for Windows. Yep. So all
that is safe, but you can also provide
it with, you know, service account token and
things like that
if you would wanna specifically do that. But
you we typically recommend just authenticate with the
AWS CLI, g cloud CLI, and then the
DevPod CLI will essentially call that other CLI.
Yeah.
Yeah. That makes sense to me.
So
let's do DevPod provider ad.
Let's pull in a provider,
and
I have a project called Rawkode Academy.
I'm done.
So
I do a list.
Yeah. Okay. So Docker is set to the
default and
from the docs we see Actually, it made
Google Cloud your default. Yeah. So in the
CLI, I think it
yeah. It it does the latest one as
as default.
If you do it in the UI, there's
a little checkbox that is, like, default checked,
and you can uncheck it. That would set
the false flag for this one.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. If you click on add provider, you'll
see that as well.
It's kind of funny in the UI when
you click add provider, just click on one
of them. It's now loading the provider YAML.
That's why it takes like a second. Right?
If you switch to another one, it will
load again for just a second because it
always pulls it live from from GitHub.
Oh, so you have the ability to really
tweak and modify this without having to push
updates to desktop applications all the time. That's
pretty neat. Exactly.
That is the whole idea. And if you
click on this plus symbol there, that's the
way to add your custom providers.
So you can write a provider, put it
in a git repository, and it will essentially
pull it from there.
Alright. Well, let's find Angen.
Yeah. That's choice provider. I I don't know.
Do you have a scale account?
I do have a scale account. So
Oh, nice.
DevPod provider scale.
So how much code is that? I mean,
seven commits. I'm assuming He actually went the
fancy route. So the simple route is to
just have a provider YAML file that then
just,
like, literally has, like, batch commands in it,
right, to call, like, g cloud, you know,
create a VM, etcetera, right, via the CLI.
But he went the fancy route by actually
making it a Golang based provider. So I
was, like, super impressed when I opened this
up, and I'm like, oh, wow. This is
legit.
Alright.
So while I add this provider, we do
have a question from Russell at the chat,
so let me pop that up.
Russell is asking that he's in a reference
to open Versus code,
And he's curious if that is
the one the real code, but the open
source one without the Microsoft metrics.
And if so, do you have custom config
as the last time he tried to use
code OSS and needed a flag to enable
it to connect to dev containers.
Does that make sense? That's why I think
With the regular
yeah. I think the regular Versus code you
run on your desktop,
I I haven't tried it with
code OSS, just with the regular Versus code.
But I think what you are aiming at
is, like, the browser
based version. Because I think we got an
issue about this as well a couple of
days ago where folks have requested
for us to use, like, the,
you know, the the non open source version
in the browser. Because they are apparently, I
didn't know that either before the issue was
open, that there are differences between the pure
open source Versus code, and, apparently, there's some
other version of it.
And we run the pure open source one
in the browser apparently.
But locally, it's whatever you have in your,
you know, whatever your Versus code
says when when you have it in the
path. Right?
Yeah. Actually, I think there is some weird
things with the open source one. I don't
think you can access to a lot of
the extensions because it uses a different extension
marketplace rather than the official Versus Code one.
But I don't know if that's changed. There's
been a while since I looked into that.
Okay.
Let's add this provider.
So click go.
Oh, he's broke it.
His provider dot YAML seems to be incorrect.
Is that expected? Interesting.
Maybe we have to point it. Oh, yeah.
Can you just do the release
asset?
Yeah.
Maybe we need that.
Copy a link to the provider dot YAML?
I think so.
Oh, yeah. So it can either be a
URL or a local path to provider file.
Or okay. So maybe actually, what I should
have done is just do
this.
Yeah. There we go. Oh, perfect.
Alright. So we could add some scale away
credentials here, but I have already configured my
Google account. So let's let's go with that
make my life a little bit easier for
today.
So
now we need a project.
Let's pick one of those ones
that were the example ones with the dev
container dot JSON.
So do you have a a language of
choice?
Oh, it seems like you're a Rust fan.
I'm not an expert, though. Yeah.
Let's do it. Alright. The UI is, like,
the the desktop project
is written
in Rust as well as far as I
as I know. I actually I I was
very nosy, and I went to look at
the code.
And I've seen issues in Tauri,
which is Yeah. This really cool framework for
building desktop applications with, like, a Rust tool
chain underneath it. So, yeah, I was very
excited to see that. I think it's awesome.
Okay. Yeah. I was a little skeptical in
the beginning when the engineering team suggested that
because there's other, like, more, I guess, mature
frameworks at this point. But I'm super happy
with with the result and, like, the team
said it was, like, a lot of fun
to this. And they have a lot of
cool features, like, regarding, like, auto updates and
things like that baked in.
Seems to be a very, very smooth experience.
Yeah. Definitely. It seems to be gaining quite
a lot of momentum too. I think a
lot of people are are struggling with Electron
these days because, like, the overhead of running
electron apps is just getting worse and worse.
I'm not sure how Versus code Yeah. To
keep their editors snappy, but
I don't I don't I I struggle with
electron apps these days. So Tari seems to
be a pretty good approach. Plus, because it's
written in Rust, you can actually use WebAssembly
plug in models as well, which just makes
it even cooler. So
yeah. Very cool project.
Alright. Now the team was really proud of,
like, getting the size down. And I think
it's, like, under 30 megabytes now to download
DevPod, and it's quite slim.
Wow. Some of the command line applications I
build are bigger than that. So
that's great.
So this right now is creating a VM
on Google Cloud. Right?
So I'm assuming this may take just a
few seconds.
And I'm assuming, please correct me if I'm
wrong, that you're just stuffing a whole bunch
of user data into, like, the cloud config
of some kinds to kinda boot that bootstrap
it, get it to a point where it
can function.
Yeah. So we have this DevPod agent that
gets injected into the VM,
and then we launch docker inside the or
install docker within the VM.
And then we launch the container that you're
then connecting to inside that VM as well.
And
we essentially connect through that DevPod agent
to that container. That's like essentially giving us
just like SSH connection
to the machine and then to the container
that runs on that machine.
And how's the authentication handled between that agent
and my local machine?
I think that's such a, a SSH keypad
that gets generated
locally.
And we, like, we inject that into the
VM, right, with the with the agent.
Okay.
And then regular, you know, I think the
first, like, connecting with the machine is just
like regular
g cloud commands or, like, we're using, I
think, the
four four g cloud and AWS, etcetera. We're
not, like, having to call the CLI directly.
I think we kind of use their client
libraries under the hood
or a mix of both,
whatever is available. Like, Kubernetes, obviously, you know,
GoClient,
etcetera, just connects to it.
Cool.
Well,
let's
let's dig a little deeper on this. Right?
So
it's it's just my local Versus Code, which
I love. Right? Browser ones are fine, but
I spent a lot of time crafting my
config and my extensions for Versus Code. That's
a really strong
I'm I'm happy with this.
I could open this terminal here, and I
can do cargo run, and we should see
hello world. Right? But I gotta be honest.
I do hate this terminal in Versus Code.
Can I do, a DevPod SSH?
Is that a thing?
What do mean DevPod SSH?
Alright. Well well.
Like, can I just can I use my
own terminal? Oh, you mean, like, outside in
your terminal? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That
would be the that would be the VIM
extension. Right?
To do it that way. Obviously, it's just
because the VIM extension said
in fact, let's split this. Right? Because the
VIM extension told me to do SSH
workspace
demo dot DevPod,
which also works, which is also very cool.
Right?
I'm assuming
I didn't really wanna show my SSH config,
but it should be okay, I think. I'm
assuming something's just yeah. You're just injecting something.
Yeah. It's just being added.
Correct. Okay. Good. And there's the SSH keys,
so we can actually see how that authentication
is handled and there's a DevPod directory with
the keys available.
So that's pretty neat.
But this is this this to me is
the ideal workflow. Right? I've got
what is now a Linux machine AMD sixty
four.
We've got
three cores
and 16 gig of RAM. Not bad. I'm
hoping we can tweak that. And I've got
my own Versus code with my own extensions.
I can have been in the terrible terminal
and just work the way that I want.
So that means I can say hello
from
Linux.
And now my days of problems
oh, I didn't put into the right word
there.
Where
would my app be? Let's let's see. Workspace
is Rust demo.
Now we could do cargo run. I know
my days of having problems with my m
two Mac and pulling containers and stuff. And
you told me this gives me a Docker
daemon. Oh, it doesn't.
Okay. Yeah. I'm not sure if you actually
have access from
in here. Because I'm in a container, right,
rather than being
Yes. On the host. But you can I
I think with g cloud, you could go
into the VM directly, and you would essentially
see it there?
Yeah. I wonder if there's a call for
maybe having a flag, like DevPod
SSH where I do Rust demo, but I
see dash dash host or something.
Yeah. There's actually a command because we had
to debug something.
Let me try to
open the help page.
Actually, go into the machine. We have a
helper command for this as well.
Oh, there was a DevPod machine command. Right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You can run DevPod machine SSH,
and that will drop you into the machine.
Yeah. That's what I was looking for. Well,
the machine name is different. So let's do
a list.
Oh, no. I don't have machines. Yeah. The
machine name, that's something really
So it created one VM right now, and
you saw that took, like, about a minute
or so to create that VM.
And,
obviously, that's something we can't change. Right? It
always gonna take some time to start a
VM.
So what we're actually doing is by default,
we're reusing the machine for different
DevPods.
Right? So you can have multiple workspaces.
And as long as you both if you're
using the Google Cloud provider again for another
workspace, it will create a second container on
that very same machine.
So the machine is shared by default.
Okay.
So yeah.
There were two things interesting
here. One,
I was already in the machine and I
ran DevPod machine. So DevPod was available inside
the machine, which is cool.
But when I came off of it, I
then was able to DevPod machine SSH onto
the Rust demo one, and I know I
can run Docker commands to see that.
But I guess this is gonna be really
good for most workflows unless one of my
workflows says I wanna build Docker
container images.
Mhmm. And I guess maybe there's a different
dev container set up for doing something like
that. But I guess that's not terribly important
for right now. But I do like that
I have access to the machine.
This is a
this is a three core six hyper threaded
machine with 16 gig of RAM. Do I
get to configure that?
Yeah. So in the if you open the
UI real quick, you'll see that you can
configure the provider.
And,
you know, it's just essentially defined in the
yeah. If you hit that edit button there.
Ah.
And there you can define the machine.
Right now, we have this only for the
provider,
but what we actually wanna allow you to
do is change it for the workspaces as
well. And you see on the bottom, actually,
the reuse machine right now is not checked.
So you would always create a new machine.
If you have the reuse machine, the second
workspace would be using the same
same machine again.
Ah, got it. Yeah. So I guess if
I
you say we used and configured us to
be like a,
you know, n two standard 16, which is
probably I'm not sure off the top of
my head, but probably a decent size machine.
I could reuse that for multiple projects and
always get the create that Correct.
Yeah. You can also expand these, like, agent
options there, if you go back to that
screen.
And that's where you can see things like
inject docker credentials and check grid credentials,
etcetera, you know. And there's probably more options
to come. That's essentially what that agent that
lives on the VM is gonna inject into
the respective containers.
Ah, so it's gonna consume my local docker
and get credentials and put them. Alright. Okay.
Got it.
How does it know
if it's inactive? Like, if I quit the
GUI, does it still does the inactivity kill?
Or
Yeah. Yeah. So that's really interesting. The inactivity
is actually managed by the agent that that
is running on the VM.
So what you're doing when you're SSH ing
is you're connecting to that agent. Right? So
that agent sees all the SSH connections
to the machine or to the workspaces on
the machine, and it essentially sees when there
are no connections.
And that's what this timeout is. So if
you would, you know, throw your laptop out
of the window now, right, there's nothing running
and no connection, nothing needs to be client
side, right,
Then five minutes later,
the agent would still it turns itself off.
Right? It turns the machine off that it's
running on, basically. That's what it does.
Nice. So it's it's yeah. It's like a
pulse or some sort of health check. And
if we're not checking in to see that
we're doing something on that machine, it's just
gonna stop itself, which I guess is good
if you do start using some of the
chunky hardware. It's like the prices get wildly
expensive. So
Yeah. And I think that's a core benefit
of of DevPod. Right? We we actively wanna
encourage people to have
machines in different environments. Right? You can have,
as I said, one in, like, your local
minikube or your local docker,
and, you know, you can run simple things
there. And then if you need to do,
like, your integration tests or an end to
end test or, you know, something more complex,
work on, like, real data,
then you're just connecting to your AWS provider.
But then you switch back to Docker again,
you know, three hours later, and we don't
want you to have to manually, like, remember,
oh, I forgot to pause this. It ran
overnight. You know, that kind of thing. That's
why we added that automation there.
Nice.
We have another question from Russell in the
chat, so I'm gonna pop that up. But
Russell is asking
if it's possible to share or reuse those
machines across multiple people within the team or
if it's local to the single user.
I guess you could, but I would not
recommend it, to be honest. Because what we're
doing like you saw, you can SSH into
the machine. Right? And if we're injecting your
Git credentials and things like that into the
machine, right, it's probably not ideal to to
to share those kind of secrets.
Yeah. Good call.
So I think there's nothing that would stop
you, right, except for your security team, I
guess.
Yeah. Well, most organizations are unfortunate enough to
have a security team. So it's alright.
I don't know if that's fortunate or unfortunate.
I guess it goes either way depending on
where your where your concerns lie.
This is a pretty cool project.
I I can see myself using this. I
mean, obviously, I'm gonna have to go write
an Equinix metal provider now so that I
can get some chunky mail and start using
this for all of my machines.
But I I definitely I really understand and
appreciate the value proposition.
I like the pluggable provider model. It's very
configurable.
And if I can write an Equinix mail
provider with just some YAML, then good. I
don't know if I've I'm gonna go down
the the complicated
smart route like Angen did, but, you know,
it's nice to have an option, I suppose.
Yeah. For sure. Yeah. We were actually you
know, after we saw that that gateway provider,
we were like, hey. We should
have some kind of live session where someone
codes and provide it in an hour or
something like that, you know, when we just
stream it. Because it's relatively easy, and there
there have been requests for,
you know, OVH and
and Hetzner and all of these, like, you
know, smaller
cloud providers. And I I think that's the
beauty of DevPod. Right? You're not restricted to
to these big environments. You're not restricted to
us creating this for you. You can just
create it whenever whenever you need it.
Yeah. Definitely. I think we're in a quite
I don't know if it's a fortunate time,
but, you know, there are a lot of
these smaller cloud providers whose pricing is getting
very competitive. And it was opens up even
to smaller teams, the ability to have these
remote dev environments and kind of give their
developer teams a bit more velocity and, you
know, the tooling that they need and the
hardware that they need without having to ship
them a new laptop every twelve months or
whatever. So it's
it's definitely interesting time.
I'm looking at the Absolutely. I think even
even us, I mean, we're we're we just
looked at the prices for, like, using it
internally. Right? And we're like, why wouldn't we
use one of the cheaper cloud providers? Right?
Like, our dev environments don't need to be
in AWS because they typically they cost, like,
three times as much as as one of
the local providers, and and it just works
the same way.
Yeah. For sure.
Alright. Well, that's awesome. I love this project.
Thank you for coming on and and kinda
walking us through it. Is there before we
finish, is there anything that we haven't covered
that you think would be good to show
to the audience?
I think there's a whole bunch more settings,
but I think people will probably explore them.
I think, you know, by clicking through the
UI, things things usually get a lot lot
lot easier to kind of find out what's
what's going on.
I think one thing I haven't tried out
myself is working with the IntelliJ suite.
So I gotta I gotta try that, you
know, the JetBrains IDs. I'm not sure if
if it seems like you have Versus Code
guy as well.
Yeah. I've I I really I have a
rule about not running Java on any of
my machines, so that rules out the entire
IntelliJ
project.
I'm
I'm not frustrated with Versus Code, but, you
know, I always keep my eyes on upcoming
editors. So you'll see that when I'm on
the the CLI, I do use Helix, which
I think is really interesting alternative to them.
And I've been keeping a close eye on
Zed as well,
but I don't think they have
any support for this sort of dev container
workflow.
So yeah. It'd probably be Versus code for
me for the foreseeable future, but always hoping
to find a new cool project.
And I actually think Zed uses Tauri as
well, the Rust desktop framework underneath the hood.
Oh, cool.
Yeah. I think given the, you know, I
think DevContainer.
Json as a as a open source kind
of standard that Microsoft wants to to push,
I think pretty much any anyone building an
IDE or, you know, even doing some in
browser
things. Right? They essentially will look at that
standard and try to kind of comply with
it or have this, like, SSH capability that
is required to to then connect to these
dev container environments.
I think that's a that's something we're banking
on. Right? That this
this will be the standard, and I'm quite
hopeful that we don't have, like I think
right now, there's, like, five or six, like,
different competing standards, And we we looked at
the space and,
you know, I we can implement
other,
you know, standards as well if as long
as it opens to us, of course. But
DevContainer was already there and it's in
you know, it's GitHub pushing it and make
it so easy for you to add it
to a repository
so that we were like, okay. This is
the first one that we wanna build on.
But I can also see us build on
on other different standards there as well and
kind of be like the glue between the
IDE, the cloud provider, and
that essentially workspace definition that lives in your
Git repository. That's really the three things we're
trying to get together here.
Yeah. I think a really
interest in approach. Not that I wanna fill
up your feature backlog by any means, but
if if you can detect in the absence
of, like, a Versus code dev container dot
JSON, if there was, like, a a shell
dot next, you know, next is still a
very it's not popular, but it's a very
good tool for building development environments.
And if you could just bootstrap
a machine with the Next system and then
create a Next shell with that,
that would be a very interesting idea for
me. And I think Next is getting a
bit more popularity especially in the container space
as people are looking for tools to build
container images that aren't necessarily Docker in the
Docker file.
And Next seems to be a bit of
a rising contender there too. But that's that's
a segue Yeah. Definitely saw some some requests
in that direction on the on Twitter as
well once we, you know, once we launch
DevPod.
Oh, there's one more thing I wanted to
mention.
If you wanna make it like, if you're,
like, a open source maintainer like we are
and you wanna make it super easy for
people to open a project with DevPod, we
also have this, like, open in DevPod button,
you know, where we register, like, the DevPod
protocol. Right? So you have this, like, DevPod
link that kind of, like, Zoom opens up
your the application and have has everything prefilled.
The only thing you need to have is
DevPod installed and at least one provider
to kind of, you know, spin that environment
up. And then we hope that will be,
you know, happening in more and more repositories
that these links get added as long as
there is, like, a, you know, a dev
container JSON file in there. Or even if
not, as we've seen, right, it may work,
but it may require some tweaking of chunks
to
get the to get the project to actually
build.
Nice. That's something really, really cool we added
right from the start too. Yeah. That's a
nice touch. It just kinda makes it a
lot easier for people, especially if you go
to that read me of a project and
you're considering, well, maybe I'll clone this and
see if I can build it and do
some hacking on it. Like, just that one
click button to get that environment that you
know is guaranteed to work is,
yeah, a very strong selling point.
Let's
finish If you wanna contribute to DevPod, there's
a button there as well.
So definitely encouraging folks to do that.
Sweet.
Let's finish with a a couple of questions
then and then I'll let you go
and enjoy the rest of your day.
But
you lost just a week ago.
What is the response
been like? Are are people happy? You already
mentioned someone maybe talked about next on Twitter.
Just tell me about what you've seen from
the people that have been reacting to the
story.
Yeah. We've definitely seen a lot of, I
think, you know, positive responses. I think the
you know, when I compare to the vCosta
launch, I think vCosta
obviously being a much more
narrow project with Kubernetes multitenancy.
Right?
It took way long to get that kind
of, like, I guess, virality that DevPod already
got within a couple of days. I mean,
it's been, like, pretty much exactly one week
at this point
since since launching it.
And, you know, there's, like, over 800 GitHub
stars. We were in we ran GitHub trending.
There were a couple of, you know, threats
on Hacker News and on Reddit going on
that were very, very vibrant. And,
yeah, I think the the biggest thing for
us was see that people already contribute to
the project. Right? There have been, like, quite
a few pull requests,
quite a bit of issues open up. We
fixed a lot of bug. Apologies to all
the Linux users who tried it initially
because, apparently, the desktop app just showed a
white window when you open it up on
Linux. I guess we could have tested that
better.
But we got that fixed in the first
two days as well. So I think very,
very exciting to see a lot of people
just, like, get hands on experience with it,
you know, because I think a lot of
projects,
you know, people may find it interesting. They
they give it a GitHub star, and that
may not actually try it. But given that
we've seen these error reports and feature requests,
we know that people actually gave it a
shot and
found some bugs or, you know, really liked
the project and and gave us that feedback.
And ton ton of people joined on on
Slack as well. We have a Slack channel
on Slack.love.sh,
not just for DevPod, but for all of
our projects.
Yep. And there's some vibrant discussions on vCosta,
but
I didn't expect the DevPod Slack channel to
have such a, you know, like a lot
of discussions going on, like, three days in
or so. That was kinda crazy to see.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, last question then. It's like,
I know you're on the weekend. It's probably
a difficult one, but what what's next? What's
on the road map for DevPod? What do
you expect to be shipping feature wise in
the next, you know, six weeks, six months?
Do you have an idea what the future
holds?
Yeah. I think the biggest thing
that
I really wanna prioritize pretty highly is these,
like, making these,
you know, provider options
available on the workspace. Like you said earlier,
hey. For this one, I want a separate
machine with more CPU.
Right? Right now, you kind of have to
always, like, modify the provider
before you create a workspace. It's a little
bit of, like, a you know,
you know, the UX could be better on
that end, and I think that's I think
that's definitely a high priority among a whole
bunch of other UX
base where just people told us, oh, I
gotta click five times here and run this
command to make this this work. Couldn't this
be easier?
I think fleshing out these things will be
will be a pretty high priority
going forward. And then, obviously, adding more and
more providers. I think we've had a lot
of requests for, like, hey. I want, you
know, to make this work in Hetzner, etcetera.
Right? So we're planning to have these sessions
where we just, you know, actively do that
with the team just like stream while we're
coding it. Maybe ideally get someone from on
the team or, you know, from Equinix on
the team or someone who wants to participate
in that session. And then, you know, that
will hopefully show more and more people how
to create these providers themselves as well, and
that would be a lot of fun.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, thank you again for joining me.
DevPod looks like a a really cool tool.
I'm looking forward to trying I'm definitely going
to be working on the Equinix metal provider
so that I can test that out and
kick the tires on it. But I I
just say thank you again. It's been fun.
And, hopefully, I'll see you again soon.
Yeah. Awesome. It was great. I'll be in
on the show again, David.
A pleasure is all mine. Thank you very
much, Lucas. Alright.
See you. Thanks a lot. Bye.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.